BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
SUSANNAH RAUB: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
RETO MEIER: This is where
the magic happens.
JENNY MURPHY: This is primarily
a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions.
PETE LEPAGE: Welcome,
everybody.
This is, I think, our fourth or
fifth in the installment of
the Chrome Apps Office Hours.
This week, we have a really cool
event with some special
guests who are joining us.
This is the AngularJS team, who
was one of the first teams
here at Google to build a Chrome
app using, obviously,
the AngularJS framework.
And they've learned a lot over
the last couple of months on
how to build these things, some
of the issues they've run
into, as well as how to
get around those.
And really, how to build a
really cool Chrome app.
So I'd like to introduce
Brad Green and Vojta--
I forgot your last name.
I apologize.
VOJTA JINA: That's OK.
Vojta, I think that's enough.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
Brad, Vojta, why don't you guys
introduce yourselves.
And we can talk about
TextDrive, this
app that you guys--
BRAD GREEN: Great.
Great.
So yeah, I'm Brad Green.
I manage the AngularJS project
here at Google.
And Vojta is one of the
engineers on the project.
And we built this
app, TextDrive.
It's a simple text editor.
And it allows you to edit text,
which is actually cooler
than you think on Chrome.
Because if you want to edit your
CRX file without having
to go rebuild the bundle, this
is a really cool thing to do.
But I think it's a really
good example of
pulling some pieces together.
Some of these V2 APIs.
We're showing you how you can
take really good advantage of
them with Angular.
So without talking too much
more, Vojta, why don't you
take us through the
app itself.
VOJTA JINA: Oh, sure.
As we said, it's just
a text editor.
So you can open files, you
can create new files--
PETE LEPAGE: Now, I just want to
interject here for one sec.
You can open files anywhere on
your file system, right?
This is not just a matter of
hey, you're limited to the
normal file system.
No, this is my file system.
BRAD GREEN: And just to mention,
we're using a MacBook
here, but this works on
my Chromebook as well.
PETE LEPAGE: Absolutely, yeah.
VOJTA JINA: Yeah.
So I can create new files.
I think a really cool feature
is the searching.
So the first thing, you
can just search.
I can search for ng-click
or something.
But, more than that, if you
start searching with forward
slash, it does this like
grip-like filtering.
So I can say ng-controller,
for instance.
And you can see how it filters
just the lines that matches
this regular expression.
And I can go edit
the text, or--
BRAD GREEN: So it collapses
all the code.
VOJTA JINA: Yeah, it just
collapsed it, so I can--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PETE LEPAGE: And it's
not just text.
But you've also got some
things in there so that
editing code becomes that
much easier as well.
VOJTA JINA: Yes.
I think the main purpose of this
thing is for editing any
sort of source code.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
BRAD GREEN: So just a
little bit more of
how we put this together.
So we're using the ACE
editor component.
VOJTA JINA: Which is awesome.
BRAD GREEN: It is fantastic.
But that doesn't make
a full app.
So as the wiring bit, we're
using Angular to pull the
whole thing together
into an app.
And then we're using these V2
APIs to be able to access all
the pieces we need to make
it a real application.
VOJTA JINA: Maybe the last thing
I could show is there
are settings, as well.
So you can change the theme--
BRAD GREEN: Fantastic.
If I want to code in the dark.
VOJTA JINA: All these settings
are synchronized through
Chrome sync storage.
PETE LEPAGE: So if I'm logged
into Chrome on one machine,
and then go to a different
machine and start editing
files, I get the
same settings--
VOJTA JINA: Hopefully, you will
get the same settings.
PETE LEPAGE: Very cool.
So that was something we talked
about last week with
the Chrome storage APIs being
able to sync those across
multiple machines.
BRAD GREEN: So it's kind
of a basic text editor.
I think the interesting part is
how this editor works, and
how we built it, and some of
the lessons we learned.
VOJTA JINA: Yeah, I think we
learned a lot of stuff, even
about Angler to about--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
VOJTA JINA: We are developing
Angular.
But sometimes it's good to
develop something with
Angular, so that you can see--
BRAD GREEN: Absolutely.
VOJTA JINA: I think we learned
a lot of lessons as well.
BRAD GREEN: So just for the
folks who haven't used Angular
before, let me just give
a brief overview.
Angular is a framework for
building web apps.
And it really helps
you build MVC--
model-view-controller
style web apps.
And it does this through
a couple mechanisms.
And you can check this
out at AngularJS.org.
We've got a ton of
code examples.
We support it through something
called data binding,
where we automatically
synchronize elements in your
UI, and the state of them, into
your properties in your
model, into your JavaScript
objects.
We also have something called
directives, which allow you to
extend HTML syntax.
So that instead of having a
whole bunch of divs and spans,
if you want to build
tabs, you can just
say tab, angle bracket.
Or, you can-- if you're not
in an HTML5 browser--
you can still say, color
picker, angle bracket.
You can make that work in
any browser on the web.
And we'll see some of these
features, and how they come
together to build a really
nice MVC-style app.
So, Vojta, can you take us
through some of this?
As a matter of fact, let's
look at the app itself.
So in MVC, the controllers
usually map to certain
parts of the UI.
And Vojta--
VOJTA JINA: And that's exactly
what it does in Angular.
BRAD GREEN: That is what
is does in Angular.
Vojta's cooked this up so that's
we can actually see
which controllers map to
which parts of the UI.
VOJTA JINA: Yeah.
So there is one root
controller,
which is called App.
And that's basically responsible
for stuff like--
it keeps some state, like
the settings, is it
open or is it closed?
Is this search dialogue
open, or is it closed?
And stuff like that.
So that's App controller.
Then we have Tabs controller,
which is right over
there at the top.
And that is responsible for
these buttons over there, in
the right top corner, as
well as all the tabs.
So creating new tab, closing
tab, focusing tabs.
Basically keeping the state of
which tab is selected, and
stuff like that.
Then we have StatusBar
controller, which, again, is
responsible for some
stuff here.
So for instance, you can
manually change the file type,
and stuff like that.
And last piece is Settings
controller, at the bottom.
And that's responsible for
changing the settings.
BRAD GREEN: Great.
VOJTA JINA: I think that's
pretty much the overview.
These are the controllers
that we use.
BRAD GREEN: OK.
Well, let's look at
some of the code.
And let's maybe zoom into
the Tabs controller.
Would you take us through a
little bit of how that works?
Maybe we'll start
on the template.
VOJTA JINA: Yeah.
That's a good idea, actually.
So this is index.html, which
is basically a template of
this whole app.
It's just one template.
And you can see this header
right over there, which is
controlled by Tabs controller.
And the first div--
that's these buttons
right over there.
And then we have these tabs,
which are done just by CSS.
So it's just unordered list.
BRAD GREEN: This is the template
of one tab, that will
get expanded into
multiple tabs.
VOJTA JINA: Exactly.
You can see, there is
this just one item.
And that's one tab.
And this whole code basically
creates one tab.
And here is when Angular comes
into play, because it says,
repeat this tab for
every tab in tabs.
Right?
So I think we might go to tabs
controller, which is actually
pretty lightweight.
And most of the stuff
is in tab service.
So let me actually go
to tab service.
And I think we might show people
adding or something.
BRAD GREEN: Yeah, let's
look at Add.
I think Add is the interesting
part of tabs.
VOJTA JINA: So here is
the source code to
actually add a tab.
And I think you can see
the magic of two-way
data binding here.
Because what we do, we
just create a new
instance of tab object.
And then we basically just
push it into an array.
So tabs itself, if I search
for this, tabs is just the
JavaScript array.
Nothing special.
So for me, in order to create
a new tab, I just push a new
tab into this array.
And this two-way data binding
automatically will synchronize
it, so that if I create
a new tab--
BRAD GREEN: Because we have it
bound to the UI, it knows
that, for every item in the
array, I will create this tab
template that you showed off.
PETE LEPAGE: I think one of the
things that I've really
liked when I've played with
Angular is that there's no
really funky data set up or
anything that I need to do.
Those are just an array--
VOJTA JINA: Exactly.
PETE LEPAGE: --of
strings, right?
BRAD GREEN: That's right.
PETE LEPAGE: That I can
just say, hey--
VOJTA JINA: Just needed
the array.
PETE LEPAGE: There you go.
Great.
Done.
VOJTA JINA: Which makes it
really easy to work, for
instance, with some
third-party code.
You don't have to wrap it
with some custom stuff.
PETE LEPAGE: And it makes it
easier, at some point, to
serialize it out, as well.
Because I don't have all this
crazy stuff that's in there.
BRAD GREEN: For sure.
Yeah.
All right so do you want to take
a look at how we maximize
the window?
Do you want to see that?
VOJTA JINA: Yeah, sure.
So that's an Tabs controller
as well.
BRAD GREEN: Let's describe
what you're doing here.
PETE LEPAGE: Yes.
Because the maximize window is
part of the windowing API,
which means that we've got
the ability to be able to
completely change the window and
size, minimize, maximize.
VOJTA JINA: I can show you--
PETE LEPAGE: Stuff we can't do
with normal web apps today.
BRAD GREEN: That's right.
PETE LEPAGE: But we expect to
be able to do with apps that
are installed on our machine.
VOJTA JINA: So this controller
just calls something.
We call it Service.
And we have App Windows
service.
Let me actually show you this.
So this service is really
lightweight.
It's just a tiny wrapper
around this Chrome API.
And I think that was one of the
lessons that I learned.
The reason for doing this tiny
wrapper, which is basically
almost empty service, I
think there are two
advantages of that.
First thing is whenever this API
changes, you have single
place, where to change it.
And for instance, this API--
BRAD GREEN: The importance
of using API.
VOJTA JINA: This API has changed
at least four times.
And then it's easy to
change it, because
there's just one place.
And you change this
single place.
And the rest of the
app doesn't care.
So that's the first thing.
And then the second thing
is testability.
Because most of those things,
like Windows close.
You don't want to do
that in unit test.
You don't want to close the
window doing unit testing.
So once you have this tiny
wrapper, you can just easily
inject different versions
during unit testing.
For instance, empty function,
or some Jasmine spy.
So that you can assert whether
it was code or not.
But that's pretty much it.
It doesn't do anything.
So that's the reason for this
tiny wrapper, which is
something that you can
see multiple times
in this source code.
PETE LEPAGE: Now you guys
saw those change a lot.
At this point, we kind of expect
and hope that we're not
going to see a lot more changes
to the Window API.
Because we are at a point
where things are really
starting to become more stable,
the breaking changes
really are fewer and much
further between.
You guys started on this
two months ago?
VOJTA JINA: This editor was
done couple weeks before
Google I/O. We did that for
Google I/O. So that was a time
when there were many changes.
BRAD GREEN: This is true.
And although this API will not
be changing, I think this
lesson still applies.
Because for me to be able to
change my code, and if I want
to reorganize my code, using
Angular's dependency injection
allows to just have a really
good, flexible code--
VOJTA JINA: Exactly.
BRAD GREEN: --no matter
what I want to do.
PETE LEPAGE: I think that's
really good point.
VOJTA JINA: Yeah.
For me, that was really the
point where I realized, oh,
this dependency injection
style.
That's really amazing.
Because you design something
one day, and it works well.
But then the other day, it's
completely broken because some
API changed.
So you fix it.
And guess what?
The other day, it's
broken again.
BRAD GREEN: And it may
not be an API.
It may be other developers
you're working with.
VOJTA JINA: Sure.
It's the same if you're working
on a product for a
customer and the requirements
keep changing.
That's completely the same.
And so suddenly, the
architecture of the original
design is not that
great as it was.
And I really believe that the
only way to manage and to keep
the code nice and clean, is
just to keep refactoring.
And the point is that, once
you have this dependency
injection that wires all these
pieces together automatically,
it is super easy to refactor.
So you do it.
If it's difficult,
you don't do it.
BRAD GREEN: Let's move on to
the Settings controller.
The settings where we keep track
of all your preferences
and where we synchronize them
across all your devices.
PETE LEPAGE: Before we jump
there, I just want to make one
quick comment to the folks
who are watching.
If you have questions for these
guys as we're going, or
as we're working through some of
these examples and showing
you this stuff, be sure to post
your questions to the
Google Developers Live page.
You can go to
developers.google.com/live,
and click on the Live link, and
post your questions on the
moderator queue just
down below.
Because we want to
take your live
questions as we go through.
So please, post your
questions.
VOJTA JINA: I think that's
what this is about.
PETE LEPAGE: Absolutely.
VOJTA JINA: All right.
So settings.
BRAD GREEN: So yeah, let's
look at the Settings
controller.
Is that what we have up?
VOJTA JINA: Yeah.
Sure.
Again, this controller
is almost empty.
I think that's another lesson
that I learned during
building this app.
Which is, regarding to Angular,
that I think it's
good to keep the controllers
really lightweight, because
then it's way easier to
move things around.
So for instance, I remember
moving this Search dialogue.
And at that time, I had it
inside controller [INAUDIBLE].
And it was kind of difficult
to move it to a different
place on the page.
Because everything that is
inside the controller is tied
to the position of the app,
because the controller has a
specific position.
So my lesson was, put more
stuff into services.
Most of the controllers are
just publishing stuff into
scope, so they are accessible
from templates.
BRAD GREEN: Fantastic.
So walk us through how
this works, though.
VOJTA JINA: All right.
BRAD GREEN: Into the
service itself.
VOJTA JINA: So Settings.
Let's open the Settings
service as well.
PETE LEPAGE: And as you're
opening that up, one of the
other things I'll comment on,
all of this code is available
on GitHub today.
So you can go to the GitHub
URL, which we can, in a
minute, put on screen.
But you can go to GitHub.
You can pull this code down.
And you can play with
this code yourself.
You can go look in and see
how everything works.
You can try seeing how all of
these different services work.
If you want to try and move
something from one place to
another, and see what you
were just talking
about, you can do that.
So all this code is available
for you to go play with.
It will work on Chrome today.
VOJTA JINA: All right.
So the Setting service.
That's the source of
the [INAUDIBLE]
that keeps all the states
about your settings.
And there's a bunch of other
components that communicates
with the service.
So first thing is the view.
That's the part at the
bottom, like here.
And the communication between
the view and the Setting
service is down through
Angular data binding.
So again, whenever a user
changes anything-- like
whenever I change the select--
it immediately changes
the model.
That's Angular business.
BRAD GREEN: We say model.
These are just variables
in your app.
Just properties--
VOJTA JINA: Just objects,
properties.
Another thing that is in the
game is the ACE editor itself.
Because as you can see, most of
these settings are actually
related to ACE editor.
And ACE editor has getters
and setters.
So there is a tiny wrapper
around ACE editor which
translates changes to this
settings model, and calls
proper settings, getters and
setters from ACE editor.
So for instance, if I change
the theme, it will call ACE
editor set theme to something.
And the last piece
is the storage.
Because as we mentioned at the
beginning, all these settings
are synchronized, of course,
across all the devices.
So at the bootstrap, the
settings loads all the data,
all the settings from Chrome
storage, Chrome storage sync.
And when you close the
app, it saves the
settings back to the storage.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
Now are you listening for
events that may happen?
So if I'm on two computers, and
I make a change on one,
Chrome fires an event
that says, hey, this
data has been updated.
Are you guys listening
for that today?
VOJTA JINA: No.
We don't.
But you are welcome to send
us a pull request.
PETE LEPAGE: So that's
one of the other cool
things you can do.
And we talked about
this last week.
That you can say, hey, I want
to go listen for events.
So that if you go update it on
one computer, you get that
live update on the
second computer.
VOJTA JINA: You could do that.
We did not, but you could.
PETE LEPAGE: And config settings
for an editor, you're
usually not editing
on two computers.
BRAD GREEN: Unlikely.
But I think it would
be a cool demo.
It would be a great
part of TextDrive.
And like you say, this
is on GitHub.
We'd like to see everybody
add to it.
How cool is it that there's
a text editor that
anybody can play with?
You can add to your favorite
feature to it.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
That's pretty neat.
VOJTA JINA: So I think we
might actually show the
dependency injection.
At least a little
bit display--
BRAD GREEN: Yeah,
we were talking
about dependency injection.
Maybe let's dive just a
little deeper into it.
VOJTA JINA: Because what
dependency injection does,
even this is a simple app.
The hard work is done
by ACE editor.
BRAD GREEN: For sure.
VOJTA JINA: Let's be honest.
And still, we have about 12
services and four controllers.
The so that's a lot of
components playing together.
And then, you need to wire all
these components together to
actually get your app.
And that's exactly what
dependency injection does.
So if you look into this
concrete example.
So let's look into Settings
controller.
So when Angular sees Settings
controller, which is at the
bottom of the page, it says, ah,
I need to instantiate this
controller.
So here is the constructor.
And it first looks into the
constructor arguments, and it
sees, ah, I need Settings
service first.
So it goes to instantiate
Setting service first.
BRAD GREEN: And it knows this
by the name "Settings." And
you're going to show us how
we've told Angular, that when
you see Settings, create
the service first.
VOJTA JINA: So the dependency
injection, or Angular, goes to
settings, construct,
and see, OK.
But in order to instantiate
Settings service, I need to
create storage first, and
et cetera and et cetera.
So this is the way dependency
injection resolves all the
dependencies doing runtime.
And you don't have to
worry about it.
Every component just declares,
defines, its
dependencies, and that's it.
And this makes it super
easy to refactor code.
Because anything like adding
new stuff, like adding new
service, like maybe adding new
features, or even extracting
stuff from existing service
into new service--
refactoring--
it's super easy.
BRAD GREEN: And it makes your
code very short, too.
Because normally, in your code,
either you've got this
big, main method, where you're
kind of wiring stuff together,
where you create something that
it needs something else,
or you create that, or you
ask for it, or you
have to locate it.
And here, you just ask
for these things.
And they get automatically
passed to your function.
VOJTA JINA: I think it really
enables you to do refactoring
so you actually do it.
Because it's easy.
So why not?
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
So let's maybe let's review
some of the APIs
that we used for this.
Do you want to take us
through some of that?
VOJTA JINA: I think the most
important API that we used was
a file system API.
So basically, reading all the
files, and writing to files,
is done through
chrome.fileSystem.
I think we can send links
to docs afterwards.
BRAD GREEN: Yeah.
So we've got the links
to the docs.
But one of the things that's, I
think, interesting about the
Chrome File System APIs that's
different from the HTML5 File
System APIs, is that it allows
you to open files anywhere on
your computer, right?
So that I can go edit that
document that's sitting in My
Documents folder, or
something else.
I'm not limited that
specific set.
VOJTA JINA: Exactly.
PETE LEPAGE: I can also save
anywhere across my computer.
So if I want to save it to the
My Documents folder, or--
VOJTA JINA: And there are
still a lot of security
restrictions.
So it should be secure for
the user at first.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
It's not going to let me just
go randomly open a file and
not tell the user.
VOJTA JINA: So for instance, at
this point TextDrive can't
re-open previously opened files,
because there is no way
to open files without actually
bringing up the pop-up.
So the user has to explicitly
say, yes, I'm fine if
you open this file.
And you have writing
permissions
to the file as well.
So File System is definitely
the most important.
Then we use the Chrome
Storage.
We are using Chrome Storage Sync
so that it's synchronized
in between devices.
Again, the cool thing is that
you have just the storage that
you write to and read from.
And it's synchronized
across the devices.
You don't worry about that.
BRAD GREEN: There's one more.
So you want to talk
a little bit about
Content Security Policy--
CSP?
VOJTA JINA: Sure.
BRAD GREEN: So the
Chrome apps.
We want them to run.
And users want to know that
they're not going to do
nefarious things to
their machine.
And so we need to comply with
the Content Security Policy.
And Angular will implement
this for you.
It'll set Angular into
a CSP-compliant mode.
On Chrome, we can actually
auto-detect this.
There's nothing for you to do.
On other platforms, we've
got a tag you can use.
VOJTA JINA: There's a directive
that you put onto
body, or an HTML tag.
You put NG-CSP.
And that would enable CSP.
Angular itself is pretty
fine with that.
There is just one thing
that we do.
When we instantiate a new
function, which is something
that is not secure, so you're
not allowed to do that.
Sorry.
BRAD GREEN: Good.
Good, good, good.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
So that's actually a change
recently in Angular.
Because it used to be that, if
I wanted Angular to go into
it's CSP safe mode, I had to go
and put that into my head,
or into my body, off the
bat, every single time.
But now, I don't have
to do that.
So it makes my development
a lot easier.
BRAD GREEN: Well, we worked
together I this.
PETE LEPAGE: Absolutely
BRAD GREEN: This was something
we explored
together, which was great.
PETE LEPAGE: This has been a
really great learning project
for all of us, because we've
been able to really go, oh,
building a real app?
Here's a problem that
we've run into,
and a concrete example.
How do we fix this?
We found one, earlier
today, where we were
talking about zooming.
On Chrome, you can do controls
shift plus, and zoom in.
But if you're running a Chrome
app, controls shift plus
doesn't zoom in on
the Chrome app.
So as we are starting to do
these demos, we went, oh.
Oh.
OK.
Well, we're going to go
file a bug on that.
So after our office hours
today, go have a peek.
You'll probably see a bug in
there, filed by one of us, to
say, we need to be able
to support zooming
on our Chrome apps.
VOJTA JINA: Yes.
BRAD GREEN: Yes, for sure.
Well, fantastic.
So we've got URLs.
AngularJS is just at
angularjs.org.
For the V2 APIs--
we have a URL for that.
We can toss that up in a sec.
But you can also get to that
always by going to
developes.chrome.com, and
clicking on the Chrome apps
link there.
You can get to all of
the documentation
for the special APIs.
You can get to the documentation
for just
generally the Hello World.
And you can also get to all of
the samples that we have.
So beyond the TextDrive app that
you guys have, we have an
entire GitHub repo, where we
have probably about two dozen
different Chrome apps.
If you had a look at our Google+
developer page last
week, we showed controlling
an AR Parrot Drone using a
gamepad controller through
a Chrome app.
We filmed some more footage
of it last night.
I tried to get the
video together.
And I didn't get it.
But keep an eye on the
Chrome developers
page today or tomorrow.
And we'll get that up.
It's pretty cool to be able to
control a helicopter through a
Chrome app using a gamepad
controller.
We're just going completely
out of the box.
We want to make it possible
for developers to write
applications that they just
haven't been able to write on
the web before.
BRAD GREEN: And then the last
thing, of course, is the URL
to GitHub for the TextDrive
app itself.
We'd love to see some
crazy pull requests
coming for that app.
PETE LEPAGE: That would
be really cool.
BRAD GREEN: Please use it,
and please add to it.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
VOJTA JINA: I think we have
a YouTube question?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Why don't we start jumping
into the questions?
We've had a whole bunch come
in in the meantime.
So the first question is,
"Updating or rewriting jQuery
plugins using directives still
feels a little bit foreign,
and could use some more
real-world examples.
It would be great to have a
commented version of some real
directives done correctly,
such as the Angular
Bootstrap." Do you guys
have plans to do
some more of those?
BRAD GREEN: Yeah absolutely.
Good question.
So there are a couple projects
that do this.
One of them is called
Angular UI.
It's not something we do, but
part of the community of
Angular is building it.
Just go on GitHub and search
for Angular-UI.
You can see a bunch of
great examples there.
VOJTA JINA: This question is
really related to Angular, but
it pops up very often.
And it really depends.
There are jQuery plugins that
are, actually, easy to wrap.
And there are jQuery plugins
that are not
that easy to wrap.
It depends.
To be fair, I think this is
some place that we could
improve Angular.
We could make it easier to work
with some of the really
key components.
And maybe we need to go talk
to the jQuery guys.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So the next question
is actually a
really interesting one.
From somebody in New
Haven, Connecticut.
His comment was, "This makes
me a little bit nervous,
because part of this page seem
to have gone dangerously close
to inline JavaScript, in the
style onclick and friends.
Do you have thoughts
on this matter?"
BRAD GREEN: Yes.
So you're seeing a bunch of
attributes inside the tags,
now, that we've added
in Angular.
And this feels like, OK, that's
just like onclick.
Why is that not just onclick?
And maybe, Vojta, you've
got some comments.
But one of the key differences
is that onclick is a global
name space entity, and it has
all of the problems of
testability and leakage into
the rest of your app.
VOJTA JINA: In general, you can
say, I think pretty much--
BRAD GREEN: The Angular
version does
not have this problem.
VOJTA JINA: Yeah.
I think pretty much all the
problems that this onclick
handlers suffers from,
Angular does not.
BRAD GREEN: So it is
a good question.
I think we've got a presentation
tonight at our
meet up on Angular.
If you can join us for that or
see the video afterwards,
we'll go into that in
a lot more depth.
VOJTA JINA: It's going to
be about directives.
PETE LEPAGE: So where can they
find the video afterwards?
BRAD GREEN: If you go to our
blog, just at angularjs.org,
and click on blog.
Or if you just go to
blog.angularjs.org, you'll be
able to find that.
PETE LEPAGE: So that'll
be later tonight?
BRAD GREEN: That's right.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
VOJTA JINA: Or there is a
YouTube channel, I think.
BRAD GREEN: And there's
a YouTube channel.
That's right.
Just AngularJS.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So Dennis wants to know why
TextDrive isn't on the Chrome
Web Store yet.
And I think there's
a good answer, but
I'll let you guys--
VOJTA JINA: I think the first
answer is that it doesn't run
on stable Chrome.
PETE LEPAGE: Yes.
BRAD GREEN: And as soon
as it does, we'd love
to put it up there.
VOJTA JINA: Yeah, for sure.
PETE LEPAGE: So the big thing
right now is for web
developers who are building
Chrome apps, you can't upload
them to he Chrome
Web Store yet.
We're still really working
through and making sure that
we get everything stable,
we get everything right.
We're not 100% positive
that there will be no
more breaking changes.
We think we're there.
But we're not positive yet.
So we don't want to allow
developers to upload code only
to find that, oh, we just made
that one last breaking change
that we had to do and
all of a sudden,
everybody's app stops working.
So we'll make some pretty big
announcements, and do a
Hangout here when developers
can start uploading those.
And we'll work with you guys to
make sure that yours is one
of the first to get uploaded
and available to folks.
So the next question is from
Martin in Denmark.
But he says, "I love AngularJS,"
but he's not so
fond of JavaScript in general.
"Will we see Angular in some
form of Dart?" And he's got a
little smiley face afterwards.
BRAD GREEN: That's
a great idea.
I don't see any reason not to.
We've talked to the
Dart team a bit.
We haven't started working
on it, but yeah.
Sounds great to me.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Awesome.
VOJTA JINA: Angular is ideas.
It's not coupled to--
BRAD GREEN: That's right.
It's an--
VOJTA JINA: --a language.
BRAD GREEN: --idiom
for developing.
And we're not tied
to JavaScript.
Though we like JavaScript.
Though we like Dart, too.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
So we did mention that the code
is available on GitHub.
Denis did have a comment.
Not so much a question.
But GitHub is, apparently,
not so happy right now.
You will be able
to go grab it.
The URL that we provided
will still work.
So you can go to that URL
for the code, and
pull it down later.
VOJTA JINA: GitHub is awesome.
I'm pretty sure it's going to
be OK in a couple of hours.
PETE LEPAGE: Exactly.
Hopefully it'll just be
a couple more minutes.
I'm sure they're working
pretty hard right now.
So this is a little bit of
an in-depth questions.
So I'm going to try and read it
as best I can, and not mess
it up too much.
So Project in subdirectory.
And they they added a base
source tag that says
subdirectory, thinking the
HTML5 URL would be
sudir/route1 and subdir/route2,
and for older
browsers it would be
subdir/#!route1, #!route2.
But instead, it came out
as subdir/#!/route1.
Is that--
VOJTA JINA: I got lost.
PETE LEPAGE: Well let me
show you this code.
It's the one highlighted
in blue there.
And he's trying to figure out,
is that probably a code bug
for him, or is that
a config thing?
BRAD GREEN: It's probably
a config thing.
But if you would post to the
AngularJS mailing list, with a
snippet of your code, or a
jsFiddle example, we'd love to
look at it for you.
PETE LEPAGE: Perfect.
And where can they go for
the mailing list?
BRAD GREEN: So again,
go to AngularJS.org.
And there's a menu
called Discuss.
Go to Discuss.
And then the mailing
list is there.
PETE LEPAGE: Excellent.
So for some of these things,
it's a little hard for us to
really be able to
dig into these.
BRAD GREEN: Could be a bug.
We'd love that, too.
VOJTA JINA: I think it's more
likely about configuration.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
So, "How do you determine if a
jQuery plugin can be easily
incorporated using directives or
not?" And this is from Vij
in New Jersey.
VOJTA JINA: I would say it
depends how much stuff this
jQuery plugin does, with
regards to dome.
As long as it can live inside a
div or something, and there
do whatever it wants,
it's fine.
But as long as it starts doing
things like, very often, these
model windows and stuff, it does
stuff like, oh, I'm going
to remove this is dome.
And I'm going to put
it somewhere else.
And then I'm going
to delete this.
And I'm going to
create a clone.
And this is something that
angular compile doesn't like.
Because once you change
the structure, it's--
BRAD GREEN: Yeah.
If they're very invasive to
the entire page, it can be
problematic.
VOJTA JINA: Especially if you
need angular binding inside
this component.
BRAD GREEN: Though in the
angular-UI project, I know
that there are some examples of
those type of things, like
the modal dialogues.
So go take a look.
And I know some of them use the
Bootstrap code for that
instead of jQuery UI.
But I think you can get the
same effect you want.
VOJTA JINA: Yeah, but I think,
actually, Twitter Bootstrap
might be, in most of
the cases, easier.
Because you can just
take the CSS--
BRAD GREEN: That's right.
VOJTA JINA: --and do the
JavaScript part with Angular,
which is actually way
easier and faster.
So I think that--
BRAD GREEN: Yeah.
We are big fans of Twitter
Bootstrap for that reason.
And it looks great.
PETE LEPAGE: It is
very pretty.
We're almost out of time.
I want to encourage anybody to
add any other questions they
have to our moderator page.
But one of the things that I
wanted to say is, in the
learning that you guys have been
doing building Angular,
and building Chrome apps, what's
the biggest learning
thing that you guys have taken
away in terms of building a
Chrome app that you think
our viewers would
learn the most from?
BRAD GREEN: Vojta, you
did all the work.
So maybe you should answer.
VOJTA JINA: Well, I think
we mentioned pretty
much all the stuff.
So with regards to Angular,
definitely keeping controllers
light, and putting more
stuff into services.
That's one thing I learned.
I learned--
BRAD GREEN: What do you think
about building an app
versus a web app?
Anything specific there?
VOJTA JINA: I don't know.
I ended up wrapping all the APIs
into services very often,
so that I have just really
tiny wrapper around the
service that I can mock
up around the service.
BRAD GREEN: This was good,
because sometimes there is a
difference between running it as
a web app and running it as
an app on Chrome OS.
VOJTA JINA: Good point.
BRAD GREEN: And this dependency
injection will
allow you to switch it in a
very, very transparent way.
VOJTA JINA: I think we have
a good example of that.
And that's actually
the storage.
Because we said we are using
Chrome Storage Sync.
But if you ran this code just in
regular Chrome, there is no
Chrome Storage.
So we fall back, and we
use local storage.
Let me actually open this up.
The local storage is completely
synchronous.
But Chrome Storage Sync is
completely asynchronous.
And you don't want to have
service that is sometimes
synchronous and sometimes
asynchronous.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
VOJTA JINA: That
kind of sucks.
And it's difficult to
work with that.
So what I did is just wrapping
this service, and basically
creating wrapper.
So that even the local storage
is asynchronous.
And the rest of your
app doesn't have
to worry about that.
It's just asynchronous
all the time.
BRAD GREEN: We did an impedance
matching exercise,
so that you can run as
an app or on the web
with the same code.
VOJTA JINA: And again, with
dependency injection, you have
these two versions
of this service.
And you just inject whatever
version you need, depending on
the platform.
BRAD GREEN: It's a lot cleaner
than having a big switch
statement, or a whole bunch
of ifs all over your code.
VOJTA JINA: Better than having
one storage with a lot of ifs.
I think it's easier to read.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Well, I want to thank
you guys.
We're pretty much out of
time at this point.
And you guys have done, I think,
a really great job of
introducing our viewers to
Angular, and talking about
some of the learnings
that you've had
building Chrome apps.
As well as where they can go
learn more information about
taking TextDrive apart and
using it themselves,
understanding how it works, and
some of the best practices
for building Chrome apps.
We're going back again next
week, next Tuesday, same time.
We're just figuring out
what our plan for next
week is right now.
But today, most of the other
guys who you're used to seeing
aren't here, because we're
doing a hackathon.
And we've got a whole bunch of
people who are sitting down,
building apps, doing some
really cool stuff.
So I think, probably next week,
we'll spend a little bit
of time talking about the cool
stuff that everybody built,
some of the lessons learned,
and giving you some of the
great lessons, and showing off
some really cool things.
So with that, I want to say
thank you to Brad and Vojta.
And thank you for tuning
in and watching.
And we'll join you next week.
BRAD GREEN: Thanks
for having us.
This was fun.
VOJTA JINA: Thanks
for having us.
PETE LEPAGE: Thanks,
everybody.
Bye-bye.